it's time now for one more thing some
people asked me on Twitter what's that
thing around your wrist it's a bracelet
I have says every day is a victory and
on the other side full-court press on
ALS ALS is Lou Gehrig's disease and I
have a special guests here my man and
Michael Heinrichs over here in studio
who came up to visit and watch the show
today he's behind the organization that
raises awareness for ALS and also raises
money for funding for medical research
as well so I just want to give a special
shout out to my man Mike who's in the
studio today Greg Gutfeld yeah he's
actually uh kind of a bigger fan of me
more of a we're gonna talk to him about
that which allows me to make really
crude jokes to him he just laughs
actually he types that types out the
laughs which I love